I did the twist thing for the thumbnail
I'm not going to do it in the intro
spider-man homecoming spider-man of the
MCU finally gets his first film and I'm
gonna do what I tend to do when I get a
reviews are close to one in the film
action premieres which is I'm going to
talk as spoiler free as I feel I can get
away with for the first chunk and I will
tell you when I'm going to start to get
the spoilers so starting out with just
the broad overview it's good it's very
good I it's funny watching it it's not
particularly showing so watching it I
was there were not a ton of moments that
were like oh my god moments like I mean
purchased for comparison like the the
airport fight in Civil War is a good
point of comparison or the whole time
rewind battle at the end of Doctor
Strange there there is nothing like that
as while watching if it was a part of me
that I don't want to say was unengaged
but I like okay this seems a little
lower key but honestly that's right
that's correct and coming out of the
film because I walked home and so they
gave me all the time to think about it
because I wasn't to focus on driving or
anything and I the more I think about
this movie the more I like it I think
pretty much everything about this
approach is right and is correct not
just for the character but for the
character in the entertainment world we
now live in because they do put it
another way we got our super comic
accurate version of spider-man back when
Sam Raimi did it within his first two
movies I mean there were little changes
but that you know in terms of who the
characters were how they interacted with
each other the the bones of how every
character was it was really comic
accurate so we've got that version
already this one is a lot freer to take
things in a new direction and none of
the changes that they make feel
superfluous it ever feels to me at least
that they did it just because everything
feels purposeful
so at a lot of the changes I it really
is about making spider-man for the
current young generation because there
was something oddly anachronistic about
the Sam Raimi spider-man movies because
they were set in modern days but they
kept very much the feel of the 60s in
terms of the character archetypes they
were working with and again that came
from the comic accuracy of it now
amazing spider-man they just they're
just trying too hard and even though I
think Andrew Garfield was better than
the role that a lot of people gave him
credit for the the writing was very much
one of the kids thicker is cool today
Tom Holland is not trying to be cool in
fact come on really is not cool he's not
supposed to be cool but not in the
over-the-top let's make him the world's
biggest dork way that Tobey Maguire
speed the Spider Man could sometimes be
so it was a really good balance it feels
like the whole cast feels very real um
and I'm not going to go through everyone
in the cast but Tom home we've already
seen the part he's good he's great
Michael Keaton as the vulture is really
good and he's he's an interesting
villain and he's a perfect villain for
spider-man in terms of what is
motivating the scale of things I guess
like I said that the whole thing is much
quieter it's not big it's not showy but
that really is right because this is the
movie that we've really kind of never
gotten because everybody remember we
he's always you know saving the city or
something to that extent this is us
watching him be the friendly
neighborhood spider-man he's just
swinging around trying to help and it
the threat is suitably threatening but
it's on that scale it makes sense that
the Avengers aren't after the vulture um
you know because he's not he they're
above that pay grade to deal with
somebody like the vulture but it's
perfect for spider-man and it really
everything just fits very very well in
that way and so when I say this you know
the scale is smaller it just it feels
more intimate it feels more grounded and
that and
honestly this kind of a niche we're not
getting from marble or we haven't been
getting from marble up to this point and
actually I would say that we haven't
really been getting in superhero films
in general the closest might be the
Marvel Netflix stuff that's very
ground-level but that's gritty ground
level
this isn't gritty but it is still the
ground level is bringing it down to the
hero who is down here in the trenches
with us the average people and you know
all the Avengers films they're all gay
and all the other ones that have fed
into that you know whether it's Captain
America Thor Iron Man they're dealing
with things much much bigger they're
dealing with global they're dealing with
galactic size threat spider-man dealing
with basically a super weaponized thief
and it just in really works well and
Michael Keaton is very good in the part
I think he plays it really well I think
there's a lot of interesting layers in
terms of how they build him that it
still they're true to the roots of the
character but is an interesting new take
I love the the supporting cast at the
school I love his friend Ned I think
he's terrific Liz was it was interesting
as as a as a love interest and there
were some other characters who I did
Flash Thompson was interesting I think
in a way I almost kind of want to
highlight Flash Thompson and the changes
made to him as to how they updated this
for the current young generation but
still kept the characters serving their
same function so Flash Thompson
classically is just the stereotypical
jock bully the big guy he's kind of dumb
he shoves Peter around here flash is
still very much a bully but he's not
that kind of bully because that kind of
bully just I'm not going to say doesn't
exist in the real world anymore but
feels dated and doesn't feel current
anymore and if somebody was acting like
Vanna risco you'd be like they still
make you what so he is very much bully
but you know he's he's more about the
sort of the social pressure and he's not
stupid he's a smart guy but he's about
impressing people he's about you know
making himself feel
by belittling Peter but it's not the
bullied blue kind of stuff that flashes
classically known for so it's still a
bully but it feels like a true modern
bully as opposed to this old archetype
that not only updated but we've gotten
already in the previous version of
spider-man so we don't need that exactly
again as the film went on I actually
think my favorite thing was just
spotting the differences and seeing what
was changed and I had a lot of fun with
that especially because some characters
don't get name-dropped until like later
in the film and after you've seen them a
little bit and then some names got
dropped and I ended up going oh I know
who that is
and that was really cool because things
that they had done about the character
made it not immediately obvious like on
site who that person was but once the
name got dropped and this happened with
a couple different characters so but
once the names got dropped I was like oh
that makes sense it's different but it
makes sense and I felt that a lot as the
film went along but even if you're not
deep into spider-man's comic book
origins you got to catch all the Easter
eggs because there are a ton of them but
even if you're not like me or like the
geek your post like that it's still just
really fun and oh the elephant I want to
highlight a Robert Downey jr. as Tony
Stark
because and especially he gets a scene
where he gets to be serious and I
actually really love him there we're
sort of the facade of cool easygoing guy
drops and he gets really really serious
about what's going on and moments like
that are why I am glad we are retaining
Robert Downey jr. for as long as he's
willing to keep doing this part because
everyone you know they think about you
know the snarky that could be kind of
thing and he's very good at that but
it's the emotionally sincere moments
that he really sells and I mean that was
a big part of why civil war work and
he's got a scene in this that is really
does that very well I think the one
other thing I want to address before I
get into our right spoilers is I made
the I made a point and I said this in
some previous videos of stopping looking
at the marketing after seeing the first
full trailer because I fell
like that laid out the more of the plot
than I wanted to know so I saw the
teaser I saw the first full trailer I
was like I'm done I don't want to see
anymore so how much more got reveals
after that I don't know but as far as
that first season that first trailer go
it did lay out a pretty good chunk of
the plot in terms of the structure but
there are still a lot of surprises in
terms of the nuts and bolts of how
things get from point A to point B to
Point C etc that it didn't feel like it
gave the entire movie away it because it
did it does take some tangents and it
does go some interesting places and does
linger in some interesting things but I
do still think that Sony gave way too
much in the marketing but overall this
is really good as I said the more I
think about it the more I like it and I
don't I don't have any major complaints
on this I've got a couple of nitpicky
things I'm not even sure I'll remember
to bring them up as I get into spoilers
but yeah this is really good so getting
into spoilers a lot of this is just
going to be me gushing about the
easter-egg stuff and some of the name
drops that we got we got a Mac guard
garden and I not forget the name now but
the scorpion scorpion gets name dropped
and and shows up in a post-credits scene
and it's an actor I love if you're into
gaming and all he plays vods in Far Cry
3 if you watch or from Black Keys on
that Andy's in he's really good so the
minute they dropped his name I'm like oh
that's nice Donald Glover is he's a
prowler then that was awesome and you
okay Liv I made the assumption I think
as most long-term spider-man fans did
that you know though the please please
oh that must be the Liz Allen who is in
fact his first girlfriend in the in the
comics you know before Mary Jane before
Gwen Stacy of a poor Betty Brant before
any of that there was Liz Allan she's
kind of been forgotten by time in a lot
of ways so we had assume that so when
door opened and there heard Michael
Keaton as the vulture and you realize
he's her dad you like oh crap
and so that was a great moment well
played and and the reveal of the very
end of this character I Michelle I don't
even remember her being called that
throughout the movie but her getting
saying no my friends call me MJ I had
loved that character up to that point I
thought she was a lot of fun and I loved
her dynamic towards Peter towards Ned
and just this sort of slightly outcast
but can't help but be kind of
charismatic character it's a weird
balancing act it's like I can't even
nail down exactly why she works so well
but when she got dropped out call me MJ
I'm like oh yeah
give me more of her and I love that
Liz whether she was live out on this
case I guess Liz Toombs um is not going
to be coming back into the recurring
love edition is good and she was fine
and certainly as you know in terms of an
evolution for Tom Holland as spider-man
I think she was important stepping out
in terms of him gaining some confidence
trying to have a social life and all
that but I like that she's not sticking
around to actually be the love interest
partly because um you know I I get
annoyed with love interest driven
stories and I think they had just the
right dose of it here but also because I
kind of thick of stories was like oh the
first girlfriend you have in high school
is the love of your life bull you know
ah but that happens like never so I like
the idea that he had a girl that he
cared about and there was something
there but it's not going to work and
he's got to move on from that in the
next film presumably so I liked all of
that I was nice getting jon favreau
banged happy hogan was featured way more
than I would have thought oh and when
chill chill bag is Pepper Potts
that was a wonderful sweet surprise I I
really thought we were never going to
see her again so for her to show and she
may never show up again you know if they
never decide to make another actual Iron
Man movie if he's only just appearing at
Avengers and stuff like this from now
there might never be a place for her
again and so that's fine but I kind of
liked that there's like oh no
they're so good there's they reconciled
the back yo I like that because it felt
like I think then being split fit Civil
War but I kind of like the idea he's
gotten in a good enough place that
they've reconciled and I don't need to
see more of them together but that was
just that's just a sweet surprise I
really liked that um and yeah and the
vulture I love the motivations in the
backstory for the vulture because they
make him really relatable because he's a
guy who's getting jerked around he's a
guy he's a guy who's getting screwed and
so you understand his motivation and you
know they also did sort of the classic
you know gangster and a movie justifying
you know I'm doing this for my family
and that's a little bit of a cliche but
I think that early scene because I then
where we see how badly he's getting
screwed by the system is I know I'm
gonna I'm gonna find my own way to make
this work and I think that works real I
think Michael Keaton plays him very well
I said that earlier but he he does he
does a really good job of swapping back
and forth between being menacing being
charming when he needs to be and I like
that they didn't kill him not so much
and it's ends up he must be back for the
sequel I I mean he could send me in jail
to see who I wouldn't care so much but
it was important to me that Spiderman
went and dragged him out of that fire
because that is who spider-man is that
you this spider-man is especially and
actually this is a real low body count
movie I mean there's one definite death
because the vulture kills one of his
hands the first shocker and then we get
this other guy being the chakra and I
thought that was a fun flip around um
and like there's one guy on the ferry
who gets knocked off the ferry with a
car I think he's probably dead um but
again I think that happens like in the
confusion with the vulture going on so
it's like there's a body count of two
that's really low for a superhero movie
and that's right for spider-man that's
correct for spider-man oh the other
thing that I really like I was surprised
because when I fir
happen caryn the voice in the suit when
he first started Arjuna my facts
we're why are they trying to make him
like iron man in times of zoo except his
dynamic with Karen is completely
different from the dynamics that Tony
Howard Jarvis or with Friday later on so
it doesn't feel like a return that and
more than that it basically gave a
justification and I didn't really just
saw I thought about it it gave a
justification for him to keep talking to
himself when it's just him in the suit
it gives him someone to talk to so he's
not just arguable but he said the kind
of stuff that in the comics we always
get soft balloons for or he's always
talking to himself
that's just something that doesn't
necessarily work in film because it
seems like why is he talking to himself
in common can we get a thought balloon
we get a you know a caption box whatever
so that was always a lot of things about
the Tobey Maguire is that he seemed
oddly quiet when he was in the suit I
mean yeah he banter a little bit but he
you know we weren't getting that running
you know inner thought process in Moloch
that's actually kind of really at the
heart of spider-man's presentation it's
a superficial thing of the comics I
grant but it really does feel kind of
key to him in a lot of ways so by
allowing him to talk by giving him this
AI to talk to kind of bringing that back
that was really nice plus the sleep that
relationship became oddly sweet this is
just a really smartly conceived movie
and like I said all the changes I feel
are made for smart reasons in terms of
what's being altered to make him a kid
of now as opposed to trying to make him
reflect the you know a teenager in the
60s like he was originally written to me
and like Sam Raimi kind of already gave
us I just really like this movie and
like I said by the end I was just really
enjoying catching all the changes so
spider-man homecoming it's I I don't
know where it would fall in terms of my
rankings of Marvel overall its upper
half easy um but I'm not I'm not going
to figure out exactly where we'll go but
it's up there and it is unquestionably
the best part of my movies in spider-man
2
so yeah go see it if you haven't already
God if you haven't why did you stick
through the spoiler section that's it
I'm going to wrap this up so in any case
folks have you seen spider-man home
company home company what Home Coming
what did you think of it whatever your
thoughts drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter I counselled geese give a listen
to the Council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]